so I just got to the first major spoiler
that was leaked of Joel dying and I'm
one of those people who's like hey you
gotta give the game a chance maybe
within context like I didn't exactly
defend it I'm not gonna lie I'm actually
pretty pissed at this current stage I'm
pretty pissed off at how the game
handled it I mean yeah part of me is
like that's a spit in the face of the
fans the part is like I just find it
kind of manipulative because you've been
playing as a B here and there that's
been fine but also like Joel's just
saved her life and I wish there was I
guess a big part of his like I just
[ __ ] hate a B now like Joel saved her
life it wasn't even like a moment of
conflict of like but wait a minute this
guy just saved my life I feel like I
should just be feeling what Ellie's
feeling of yeah go after her and get
revenge but I also where I'm gonna be
playing as a b2 and like I have zero
interest in playing as her now and I
kind of feel like the way it's just
handled is manipulative and not really
effective and you barely even spend time
with Joel even in and then you're not
gonna play as them but barely spend time
with him in these cutscenes but I'm
still gonna go through with it I'm still
gonna play it right now I'm not happy
I thought the game was [ __ ] brilliant
I [ __ ] loved it
those are my basic thoughts on the Last
of Us part two what's up people I'm Greg
who are you I'm Pat Hogue Pat Hogue is
with us today I'm very excited he was
one of the very first people I started
talking to about this game you beat it
so fast yeah yeah you beat it like real
I could only play in the evening after
like 7:00 p.m. and then I would be up
late I took me about close to 30 hours
to beat the game it was pretty much
every night starting at like 5:00 going
in until about 11:00 at night Oh
waking up at like 6:00 or 7:00 in the
morning playing for four hours and like
almost to a detriment of the game
because you know it's not Mario it's not
like yeah fun like I'm contemplating
like dramatic actions while like
narrative like guttural punches are
happening zoning out as I'm doing like
marathons at this game but yeah I got
through it
pretty fast we're probably gonna end up
talking about this game in a way whereas
if you've you've played the game we're
gonna be hopping around most likely so
we're not gonna be reintroducing stuff
or it's gonna be like it's just a talk
as if you've played the game to make our
life easier to make your listening
experience easier so this is the kind of
video it's probably gonna be formulated
for those viewers just letting you know
if you're expecting a cohesive a to be
this is gonna be the first video game
official review of a video ya ever done
on this channel before intentionally
especially because I'm aware that this
game has been getting a controversial
backlash especially even before its
release as I was aware of some of the
leaks every leak I heard did happen in
the game but it didn't happen in the way
of how the leak set me up for the game I
love the game if you're already here and
you're already sold yourself like
they're not gonna validate my hatred
opinion I'm sorry this won't be the
video for you but like the game
hopefully you can look at our
perspective see that there's two sexes
in the same coin and you know maybe if
you don't agree you can understand where
we're coming from yeah that's basically
the whole point of it it's like I'm
willing to discuss this game with people
who don't like it people who even hate
it as long as they've played the game
yeah I'm not interested in truly
engaging in a conversation with someone
who hasn't played
all the people who relate review bombing
it on Metacritic the day it came out it
took us 30 hours to play it like you
yeah get the experience the way it was
intended for a game that has some like
daring narrative choices for it exactly
very early on in the game I mean
obviously this video is gonna be all
spoilers but very early on in the game
Joel is killed by a B right yeah but
happy does that as he saw in that video
footage I showed you I literally was
pretty pissed off and I was like I don't
I don't think I'm gonna get on board
with this I don't think I could get on
board with a B the bottom line is if
you're not able to get on board with
playing as a be naughty maybe not even
liking her but at least understanding
her this game it's not for you alright
yeah it says you'll hate it from there
on out you'll hate the way it ends it's
like plain and simple right and I can't
fault you on that but it is funny
because of all the discourse I've heard
about the gay I was lucky to not be
spoiled I kind of look out clear so like
and I played the first last of us and
you liked it right over a few minutes
yeah yeah I loved lessons too yeah I
think I do have like problems with it
more like structurally and more like
pacing times but in terms of story
decisions I kind of posted a very long
emotional like review as soon as I
finished playing it that I look at is a
little bit over the top but I stand by
what I said up in terms of a video game
this is the kind of one that's standing
head and shoulders above the rest saying
you can do better like yeah like you
don't we're literally doing things that
you've seen in other stories but have a
different kind of impact and create
emotional like visceral reactions
because you being the one like you being
the one who played as Joel for the first
game you being the one to like have the
agency to make these decisions it's kind
of funny to see that we're in no pun
intended uncharted territory like games
I'm a true fan but it's it is really
funny of I said like there's never been
a story like this like that's not true
there have been a lot of stories where
you've had to sympathize with an
antagonist to see their point of view
but I don't think I've ever seen it like
this of you now have to be them you have
kannaway yeah so your point what I love
about this game it really deals with
this thing that I've always wanted to
see done in a movie I love revenge
stories I love a damn good room like
Kill Bill John wick or like two of my
favorite movies the thing that often I
find funny about a revenge story is the
carrot
ders peace of mind and Ark enclosure
ends at the revenge it's like they have
found their peace now because they have
got a cut yeah they got the final kill
yeah
and this game kind of sets you up in a
way where that's where they you like
kind of might be especially if you
didn't hearing the leaks that you're you
might be under the presumption that's
where the games going
Joel dies Ellie's couldn't get revenge
and [ __ ] up at me like that's what it
seems like but that's half the game
that's where you're going so but it
explores the concept though of what is
the true nature of revenge and how
devastating can it be like to me what
really impacted me especially by the the
final moments the themes of the cyclical
nature of revenge of revenge isn't
really bring closure you said when we
were first talking of like evil begets
evil good intent but selfish motivation
can often lead to devastating
consequences Abby gets her revenge but
she's clearly not at peace and she has
weight of guilt on her and she's and
she's not portrayed as a good person in
the first half of you playing us or Abby
it has had the character arc that Ellie
has Ellie is on Abby's character arc she
gets the fulfilment of getting that
revenge kind of having this like seating
thing and it's unfulfilled she lost
Owen she's now fighting for a Cause that
really was only training her to do the
one thing she was tasked for and it
takes her overcoming her preconceived
notions with Lev and Yara like as the
scars are the Sarah fights to kind of
like understand what a new purpose is
and Ellie is on that same track but it's
still a bit a few steps before whereas
like for her Abby is that like
preconceived notion of what she has
again it is that cycle the game is and
we'll talk about structure everything
but I think it both works for and
against the game of like you're
repeating these actions but it is all
about perspective and Abby she's the bad
guy like we get that but it is that it's
so easy to say that and I think it being
what a game is and I was having that
agency over Joel and having that ability
to play with him for the first game to
see people and not like what you said I
get if you can't handle like that moment
of what Abby does for the killing Joel
but I really like we're talking about
theme it really is pointed perspective
and a lot of people are talking about if
like oh I just wish I started as a B
then I get it no like that's the point
yeah it's like this weirdly there's the
it deals with
beyond perspective there's also like
they don't really ever call it out but
there's a thing about communication in
here and really the ultimate message is
forgiveness that's what was so yeah HACC
phul to me in the final moments in the
final scene when they do the flashback
to the last time Joel and Ellie spoke
with each other when Ellie let's Abbie
go it didn't quite make sense to me at
the time you get this flash of Joel and
you're like well let me get this flash
of jewel watch like an Killa and I was
conflicted I was like I've grown to like
Abbey I don't really yeah Abbey you see
in that scene where the whole point is
about forgiveness between Joel and Ellie
really there's no peace of mind to come
from this and there's only more loss to
come from doing this act of revenge and
it's so easy to hide acts of hate in
altruism and like you see like Ellie
become because that's the point of I
liked Abby more than Ellie by the end oh
you did yeah I disagree with that even
in the actions of Ellie like oh so many
I've heard the discourse being like I
never wanted to do what Ellie was doing
she was being so hateful it's like that
first half like no I killed Joel I'm on
her side I'm doing even the moment where
she has to kill Nora with the pie yeah
and you have to push the button like you
see the effects on her as a person of
but like you understand the motivation
of where she's coming from that's the
task Naughty Dog's sets up for
themselves of like getting you to
sympathize if like someone like Manny
who is like somebody I really like
started to like her Mel or Ella to be
honest the whole other like they'll be
the whole I really like it is like these
cycles and these broken things of Ellie
like would kill Abby in the end then it
would just be love coming after her then
it would just yes like and it is just
the beautiful framing device I don't
know if it was Neil druckmann the writer
like came up with about Joel playing the
song in the beginning future days what
starts with if I were to lose you I'd
surely lose myself and Ellie repeats
that throughout the game yeah to the
point where she's lost two of her
fingers she's lost Deena she's lost
everybody he's great he hasn't lost her
humanity but she's now lost the ability
to play the last thing Joel had for her
there is no place where this ends well
and it is like it is the hardest lesson
to learn it's sometimes you just gotta
let it go and yeah it's someone like
Tommy who couldn't at some point can't
walk this is amazing relationship
that's the message that a lot of gamers
are having trouble like dealing with of
like what is that satisfaction you get
after doing the thing is it worth it the
thing about that opening with Joel what
I loved about that it immediately
challenges the results of the last the
last last month the first game be cursed
last of all immediately gives way to the
perspective of playing as a be the first
time you play The Last of Us you are in
Joel's perspective right so when you're
playing that game and then of course you
want him to save Ellie but then when you
start this game yeah he lies to her at
the end of it you're like oh there's
some consequences to it oh he start this
game it had me going ding you know Joel
kind of did mess up but of course
because I'm in Joel's perspective I
don't blame him I understand where he's
coming from so then when you're looking
at it from a B it's easy to just chalk
her up to being the villain like don't
get me wrong the whole time I played as
Ellie I hated that I like I hate it yeah
I hated it the idea of switching to her
it took me a while before I could really
it wasn't until she was like tied up by
the Sarah fights and this terrified
sander and then oh this is interesting
so there's gonna be this like little
journey where she's gonna bomb with this
era like that's when slowly but surely I
start to really like Abby yeah let's
look at it format like really look at it
from Abby's perspective
she has no connection Joel she has no
connection to any of these people
yeah other than the fact of fireflies
were her family
her father was murdered and this
mysterious man named Joel murdered
everyone she cared about her father and
also prevented the Cure from being
possible in that light I'm like I can't
really fault her for hating the hell out
of Joe no but a lot of people can't get
on board that because the first game
you're playing is Joel urea now Ali's
receptor but the whole but that's my
point about like communication it's so
funny because that was the discussion
after the first last of us which I was
very much on the other side of I didn't
agree with what Joel did like you were
forced to kill that surgeon which like
the second game very retro actively
makes the kind of you know Inception
point for everything that Abby does it
always and this is what's beautiful
about that last scene where he's talking
to Ellie is like if the Lord gave me a
chance to do that a moment I do it all
over it yeah and it's it's people trying
to find these pockets of humanity in
like the end of the world the biggest
thing about this game coming out is
people saying like all the Last of Us is
perfect why would we need a sequel and
you know buddy dog
always said like well it's only if we
came up with a story for whatever reason
like I was guessing this was gonna be a
plot point but I didn't know it would be
the story of somebody coming back for
revenge based on what Joel did and at
that moment and even even in the moment
of Joel dying seeing kind of like Abby's
reaction like kind of how intense she is
how passionate she is it really locked
in of oh this was inevitable yeah like
this story was going to happen the
beginning of this game really is the
kind of emotional dilemma that players
are playing with is that Joel did an act
of kindness for himself but it's never
with that loss
that's what Ellie is about to go on his
journey of like trying to do something
for herself but she's gonna lose
something along the way the parallels
between Abby and Ellie I think are so
interesting because Ellie is so farther
along than Abby is in some ways and so
behind and yeah and I again I get the
attachment that characters like gamers
have to her but I never saw Joel as a
hero all right I saw that he cared about
Ellie and I like I cared about Ellie and
so like I have that kind of voyeurism
with her when he died and Ellie's going
out to get a B and like okay yeah I see
where you're coming from because I cared
about Joel too but you know this is a
world where that happens it wasn't that
hard of a switch for me as I'm playing
as Ellie or as Abby and it does like
Seattle day one and I'm like oh you're
really doing this you're doing a second
game is happy yeah it didn't take me too
long for me to get what Naughty Dog was
doing of like look at her perspective
and then shed the weight of like the
anger that Ellie had yeah that being
said doing a boss fight against Ellie I
didn't want to do know yeah I was I was
about to be really mad at the game when
you're fighting Ellie at the theater
breaks her arm yeah I was about to beam
up by the throat hissed at the game if I
was like you're not really gonna make me
kill Ellie are you we were texting or
like we're talking about it and I think
you got to a moment you're like I gotta
be close to the end right I'm like now
you got a bit more and the game has a
lot of those moments of like all right
they're at a farm it has to be over now
Abby's like about to fund the Firefly
it means gotta be if the game is at
times repetitive absolutely like it's
game play especially for a game of this
length it's kind of like when you watch
a movie that's pitches an action movie
and they're like it's been too long
without action we need an action yeah
because there were times I'm like do we
really need to be fighting these
clickers ready I got to point something
out really quick especially I know we're
not doing a traditional type of game
review and Sara Lee when the leaks came
out here's how at least I heard it Joel
dies early killed by a bee and then you
play as Ellie and then halfway through
you play as a bee and Ellie's the bad
guy so I was under the impression this
was all linear like though you know how
the first last of us is linear very
straightforward yeah and this one hops
around time a lot there are times where
you're just playing in a flashback so
you do Seattle day one two and three as
Ellie like you do the whole prologue
leading into it and then jumping back to
the past every now and again to see
Ellie while you're in yeah and then you
do a bee on Seattle day one with a
little bit of a flashback here or there
all the way say I'll do through where
where they collide again and then
eventually do years later like that's
the that's the way the basic structure
of it is now the idea of what those
leaks were saying that sounds like a
really aggravating experience to me yeah
I love the way they did it here where
you're you do all of Ellie pretty much
like you play as a be a little bit to
set you up yeah like I thought that was
smart over there and I think that is
smart
I do think it also would be if you just
like never played his Abby went through
all of it she's about to kill Ellie and
then you play as her for the first time
like set me up for this and I hate that
first see where she encounters Joel
where she's having to outrun all the
infected let's scare the crap out of me
intro all character thing aside I think
the thing I still stand by with Joel's
debt that still does bother me I wonder
how I feel in a second time playing I'm
a little bit earth that there was not a
semblance of guilt or contemplation at
all about I mean yes she's had her her
mind set on murdering in this whole time
they become so savage and ruthless and
she just beats the crap out of hand this
guy just did save your life there's this
girl here who's crying there's this part
of me that was kind of like I would have
liked and I think that would have been a
saving grace for a lot of people maybe
not Foley but maybe a sliver just to be
like she looks a little conflicted about
doing this but she has to I think it's
more like they don't show it as much in
that moment and it's more tease
throughout of
you kind of see Abby and that moment
have what Ellie has at the very end
where she's about to kill lev of like
how much humanity are you willing to
give up to like do what you're gonna do
yeah it's gonna call and then you see
like people like Mel
when Abby's traveling with her she's
pretty still shook by like what Abby did
so it's like clearly this is not Abby
and her normal that moment when it
flashes back to her killing Joel again
after she kills Joel it really is you
kind of have this wave of sympathy come
for her if like we're not killing the
rest of them even Owens like no no we
had like one goal so I think playing
into that how much revenge just blinds
you to humanity yeah like because a
window says we're no better than the
rest of them yeah you know that thing
that you always hear about like you know
what makes a great bad guy when when the
bad guy doesn't know they're a bad guy
they think they're the good guy this
game takes it to the max they make you
play essentially as the antagonist of
the game where when you really are
thrown into that character's perspective
you realize like well she's not really a
bad guy you know or it's not even that
she thinks she's not a bad guy it's just
that she deserves this there's
retribution my father died in this guy
like neo screwed over humanity she
thinks she's able to live with that and
then ironically humanity kind of like
clings on to where of oh that wasn't as
satisfying as an act that I thought I
could have I can't meet you on that I
liked
Abby more the thing is I get it I got to
give the game credit cuz I really was
like especially when you start over
again basically
oh god you gotta get all the upgrades
like what an emotional decision I was
like I just upgraded a leash I did all
that she like gave her more pills of her
beau could fire further like Abby just
doesn't have a knife and you really got
to be patient with it in order to see
whether and I are gonna enjoy it
it really wasn't the Seraph eye moment
where I was really like oh I'm really
starting to dig like when it's nighttime
she's hung up she gets like when she
meets Yara that whole first sequence I
thought was [ __ ] awesome
when you're fighting the stalkers like
in the wood yeah Ellie's journey though
like I said we're gonna be all over the
place with it with Ellie's journey even
with her though it's like I know Ben a
lot so let's talk around Abby because a
lot of the hate is going towards the
Abby Abby and the marketing really hit
her
in a way that he's supposed to kind of
be like talk about it yes exactly
with Ellie's journey but even with her I
think some people could find it
manipulative I personally did it of how
when she's going on this journey when
she commits certain actors like she
kills Mel and she finds she finds out
she's pregnant cuz there are these
parallels that are being drawn between
her and at like there's certain things
it's like with George Lucas says about
the prequels it's like poetry but it's
not exactly the same thing one story has
like a pregnant Deena and this has a
pregnant you know as then on the other
guy's name no when like when she kills
Mel you see how devastated she is by
this or that moment where she kills
Noren and they're having you be the one
who's pressing square you have to kill
the person of just like screw it I'm
giving full into the rage and you're
watching how Elly is morphing during her
revenge quest and what that's doing her
it even post that like I love that you
go two years later with her yeah she has
this choice she has the opportunity to
let it go
overcome her trauma but she can't let it
go and then you really think like I was
trying to like particular was gonna or
she's ever gonna like save Abby I was
like I know what moment they're gonna
try to do it could be real cheesy yeah I
really just think that every choice the
game made it honestly earned I feel like
you know talking about the first half it
is the cheap move to kill Joel like
everybody was suspecting Deena before
the leaks came out of like oh she's
going on a revenge tale her girlfriend
died which would have been a little like
rotten like not not the most like
narrative Lee gut-punching I think so
it's an easy thing for like the player
to get on her side even through all the
brutal acts like its ally and we love LA
she's from the first game you know
everyone's like I said it could be such
a cheap move and it's true but then the
cards are so stacked against Abby in a
way that Naughty Dog has to like come to
play for her Carrie I don't have any
resonance they're writing themselves
into such a corner that will be nigh
impossible to get out of that it's kind
of more daring that they put you such on
Ellie's side at the beginning your
goodness yeah not to keep going back to
that I don't think that is such a
unthought through decision of Joel
having that kind of like cheap emotional
sting to the players because even to get
some people to be like I don't know I've
got a point
like it's kind of
a goal to really like that they achieve
that I'm I'm shocked
with Joel though I think what was
upsetting to me especially at first
because even knowing he was gonna die
yeah I was prepared for that I thought
that was the last rule see of him I
thought that was it that was the end of
Joel for the rest of the game and that
was kind of frustrating to me but then
you get these like really great flash
museum the museum one when they're in
the rocket ship and giving out almost
like childhood and like I cry I mean he
has emotional he's been trying to
supplement like the psychological aspect
of Joel is like he's supplementing the
loss of his daughter with this Ellie
character right even the scene when he
she learns the truth and then that
confrontation that happens and then of
course like the final flashback you know
late and I like the way the game messes
with your perception of things I thought
when they go to that scene where Dena
first kisses Ellie and then Joel pushes
a bartender off yeah I was like oh is
this or the last conversation that's
which I but then I even thought of at
the first mission with Dena like Ellie
he's talking about like I was gonna
watch a movie with Joel so I'm like
where is that in the timeline if they're
like ending all like sad and everything
cuz I knew there had to be like another
beat but I thought for a second they
weren't gonna show it to us and it was
just gonna be yeah he died and there's
some man yeah how the game kind of calls
back to the first/last of us whether it
is those moments between Joel and Ellie
that you remember of like her being
younger him being older or even like I
thought the parallel between a B and
level of like them like need to like
learn about each other again that museum
scene of really like hammering home that
it this isn't just a game about tragedy
it's about remembering love any act of
revenge any act of anger is fueled by a
passion that feels justified and I think
the kind of beautiful part of what they
play in at the end especially when you
know I don't want to get too much into
it right now but like when Elias
drowning Abbie she has a flashback to
that reconciliation with Joel it's the
first time she's had a positive image of
him before that it's only been a
reminder of the pain and that's what's
able to break her out of the cycle I
think them knowing very well of how much
Joel if they're gonna do that in the
beginning and kill him off and make that
decision how impactful his like moments
need to be like when he's yeah doused in
even to the point where they faked some
trailers where they showed what
differently character models and scenes
that look like present table were
actually flashbacks it's yeah it's there
is a lot of conscious thought into this
relationship that isn't just you know
calling back to a first game you're
gonna see it throughout still again
makes it incredible that I'm still like
that was pretty cool I think the reason
I love Ali I mean not just because it's
only played The Last of Us part one one
time years ago I don't have this like oh
I really love Ellie the most because I
played it just in terms of like the
character like I love actually just more
relatable she's funny I don't love the
fact of it like I didn't feel as in
danger when I'm playing as a be because
she's [ __ ] like super buff
Schwarzenegger yeah built her body to
kill yeah whereas Ellie you can always
feel like this struggle and I love like
certainly they on the state of play
trailer they released the gameplay
sequence when Ellie goes to the mature
has it's like huge showdown with the w
and left where she holds that one girl
up and is looking for the oral yeah like
I loved I loved all that Elia is just
this character who I'm just more latched
on to whereas Abby is so detached from
humanity that she learns about humanity
and that's her journey essentially like
that's the most BC like cuz that's the
beautiful thing about her journey with
love especially Latin Yara because they
have this war with this Sarah fights and
and even I'm playing the game going
what's the point of this war like what
why are they happy but then that's the
way it goes in so many like that's the
way real world off and Huffer wait a
minute why why are they fighting and
again the idea of the game about it's
all about perspective and Abby has this
play as live in the next yeah if they
want to do like DLC where it's LEDs
adventures but they had this whole
conversation between Abby and Lev where
you know they talked about the profit
that the martyr that died for them
Abby's saying look how many people died
because this in love sing that wasn't
her teachings have you read her like
writings and she's like I skinned them
and labs pretty much like she would hate
this this fighting like is not what we
were based on you have your perspective
of it I have my perspective and like
even Ellie's perspective of the WLF is
just these monsters that are killing
people on sight and then not only do you
start to play as Abby
have to empathize with her you see this
community you have to pet a dog that you
yeah end up shanking earlier like I mean
to be two sides to be fair it's it's
about individualism though because the
Sara fights and the WLF no one's really
portrayed who's like it's like this
really awful person and the seek of
power what's and the power will corrupt
yeah yeah Sara fights are never
portrayed as good people and it's only
within the individuals of Lev and Yara
who are like we needed this ban from
them or or even just like you kill a
single Sara fight or you kill it W laugh
and you hear someone go Tommy or like
general so it's like they have an
internal life even at the end when
Ellie's going to track down Abby and she
faces the Radler rattlers there's always
gonna be a group there's always gonna be
like just some organization maybe
Jackson is the best version of that
where people aren't like other people
are the closest to like bringing it back
to some sensibility and it's just you
know how like an active evil can even
corrupt that in every group there's
always like you know like they're those
people who are caught by the the
Rattlers of like there's always some
ounce of and I think what this game does
great is that even in the darkest places
there's humanity in every yeah action
well I think what the Last of Us world
does so well is that they know this is a
survival game the whole point is about
survival I get the basic nitty-gritty of
this is a survival getting out of a
skirmish with a bullet and then what
would people really be like in a world
that is so hell-bent yeah on just
staying a lot here you know and the ones
you choose to trust what does your trust
level do and it's fight it for his whole
life long as talk we've talked about so
rich and story that's you know what
really hit me when I when I really start
a love Abby I know the exact moment it's
when she's protecting love mmm-hmm from
getting killed by Isaac won't let it
happen and they get away and Lev is like
you just killed her people and she's
like you're my people oh my god when
that moment happen I was like oh my god
that that Ennis that's change that's an
artic if that declarative moment yeah
about kind of the meaning of the entire
game of what everybody in this game is
trying to do is that they're fighting
for who they love and they're fighting
for like what they love and it doesn't
matter where you come from who you come
from and like I think loves character
and like the reveal of him being trans
and like everything it's just that's one
of those things oh you're just dropping
this with a confidence of you know like
what Naughty Dog does and it it just has
that much more impact when like you have
these characters who are fighting
against oppressive systems or fighting
against kind of these warring bodies and
saying we're here to preserve the purity
of what's left in this kind of desolate
yeah Ellie isn't trying to do that she's
trying to cause further destruction to
make herself feel better even though al
is my favorite character spend so much
time talking about happy I feel like the
reason why is because I just feel like
we have a different perspective you
might lean more towards positively
towards the whole happy side of things
than I do
but I still feel like I share so much of
it with you to the sense of like I just
don't share the hate I did at first you
know but I I don't now it's interesting
looking at the ending of this game
clearly Abby has suffered for her
actions like because of her revenge it
got her friends killed people she
considered family and then she's
captured by the the Rattlers and then
she like loses all muscle mass you know
and so you're like oh in a weird way
it's like gender flip of what's Joel and
Ellie from the first one yeah with Lev
and her not that there's a moment where
Ellie goes unconscious and get away from
these people the other thing with Abbey
this game has gotten a lot of flack
prior to being released for the same
crap that people get mad about all the
time yeah but you know that's J Dobie
you woke whatever I can get annoyed to
when it feels exceptionally pandering it
doesn't feel that way to me in this game
there is a moment that was circulating
the internet that people were just at an
uproar about and I never looked into
details as why I'm gonna make that clear
right now I have no idea exactly why
other than the amount of insults that
came to the body image that Abby
portrays I'm not gonna sit here and be
like I don't know you
at this [ __ ] hot like I don't I don't
think that but it's anytime I'm not like
oh I'm repulsed but you know I'm not a
VAT category you know so there's the sex
scene that she has with Owen that went
around the internet and people were like
this shocked disgusted like it was like
nah that's all overseeing every every
clickbait thumbnail it kind of hit me
when I was playing the game I wonder if
like this is only gonna feed into like
the argument more that people have who
or just I hate anything that cool even
if it's not doing it but if a kind of
resembles woke or whatever I can't help
but feel that people would probably
still have issues with the character but
I think they'd be a lot easier to adjust
to if Abby was a guy if the character
was male I don't think it would be as
much of a problematic thing in movies
and shows we've seen bad guys become
good there's a Hobson shop off
scott-free but even negan in The Walking
Dead who did a similar act to and in
some ways I feel like that was
intentional to sort of reflect that a
little bit he liked negan beat the [ __ ]
with a baseball bat to two main
characters and then he eventually
becomes like the main character in the
show is essentially a protagonist you
got two things going free that I think
you know people just hate anything
Walker SJW whatever which I don't think
ours in itself bad I don't think those
are bad things I think if you look up
what those mean I think with when it's
annoying is when it's obvious like you
got white dudes at the top row doing
pandering diversity that's when I can
get I feel like they're trying to hit a
quota versus like you have colorful
characters that like that feel built
into the actual DNA of the story yeah
like that that's where the difference
lies right and I feel like it's natural
here but I think the issues that have
like come up are just like you know
Ellie is lesbian has this girlfriend and
then on the flip side you got their
straight girl that you're playing as
who's like buffed out like a dude it's
the antithesis of like the female
characters that may be gamers who are
primarily male there's a lot of female
gamers out there primarily male who are
just not on board for it and I'm not
saying all females will like this game
it's not sure there plenty of females
who hate this game after playing it I
just think there's a lot of unwarranted
hate that ghosts in this department I
think more would be forgiven if Abby was
a guy I don't want happy to be a guy but
I honestly do think that
a political social thing that surrounds
this this character I think it's because
the game deals with it so nonchalantly
of you know that's in Abbey's character
again of she has literally dedicated her
life to one goal which is to to will to
get revenge and survive so she's buffed
back yeah she's still a woman she's
still like you know she had a
relationship with Owen as wants and
desires it's all about visual signifiers
and Elly and Deena just kind of having a
relationship or like Deena being bi but
it's just it's not the fact that it's
not a plot point the fact that it's not
like a character thing for them to
accept with each other there's a
conversation that Joel is like honestly
like girls fling all right yeah I'll
figure that out like you know he's you
can tell he's kind of a rustic
old-school guy but the confidence of the
game to just have you know characters
just be characters to have Jesse be
Asian to have Lev be trans even though
that one plays a bit more into the story
of why he's excommunicated from the the
Sarah fights you don't look at white
characters or white straight characters
in content and say like well how is that
informed by the story it's you know like
it's made written and directed by a guy
from Pakistan who you know who has had a
tougher childhood Neil druckmann has
talked about it you know you depict the
world you want to see and even in the
apocalypse there's a representation for
Humanity and just those boundaries at
that point in society don't matter it is
about survival and it's for all the
people hemming and hawing about you know
like hitting quota is trying to be
representative to seem whoa even if a
game of this caliber that is killing its
main character from the first game in
the first two hours like it's not taking
it easy it's not like taking like
narrative like it's not you know sitting
back and trying to do what most games
would do the fact that it can have the
confidence just to depict it as normal
and not make a big deal of it I think is
way more impactful than well it doesn't
feel like it's a part of the story or
like it doesn't feel like it's adding
it's just the brazenness to like just
have a diverse cast that I think the
wrong people will be up in arms about
maybe we should talk about some basic
stuff gameplay the game feels really
good I like whenever I which is funny
because I do want to talk about it but
like
you know there's ludonarrative
dissonance where you just kind of have
to like accept that a games gonna be a
game whereas this game is about hate and
you know every kill something and you're
living with it and meanwhile I'm like
I'm about to get the best headshot with
my still or like toughest part is
killing dogs I think oh yeah I mean that
whole like I can never let my girlfriend
play because there are times were like
there's certain games were it's kind of
an option yeah this one you're like oh
you gotta do a sequined you can't pass
as Leslie murder you know and I started
the game on normal and this was after
just playing the first last of us so I
was finding it pretty easy I was getting
a lot of ammo a lot of resource is that
different it's fairly similar records
have been the years it's late you know
it's it feels way better a lot of people
compare it to the no Gear Solid 5 which
is like a big stealth game with like a
lot of different mechanics you couldn't
crawl and you couldn't like there's a
lot more like refinements a lot of it's
pretty similar but it is the Rope the
Rope which everybody made a big deal of
only use it like four times the Rope
yeah no I mean the thing I take so long
to play because I relish in like I want
to find everything like I I did that for
a while I've been it's like I gotta
finish this game and I and I was able to
fuse the rope and some pretty crafty
ways to break some windows and then use
the rope to get in and be like ooh I
uncovered a new weapon I got so yeah I
get I you use the Rope a lot there's a
creative ways to use it go back to those
sections cuz I was like there were
moments of I gotta get out of the
building well good thing this 100-foot
cord was over here oh yeah there there
are times where the game a game is a
game and it's like man we gotta get past
this flooded river well good thing I
have a ladder over here then just once
it's but the game feels great like yeah
I think it's the the pacing issues of
literally starting over in the middle if
you're playing on higher difficulty like
going into a room circling 360 to find
every resource and then doing that a
thousand times the feeling of just
barely surviving in encounter and then
like coming out with an arrow left or a
bullet left you're like that's a
survival game okay that did it and you
couldn't hold people up before right
you can hold people up honey yes you
could do that in the first game but it's
much more AI reactive now of like they
have
more reactions to be like okay I didn't
realize that I don't remember that it's
very simple
honestly I was way late into the game
when I realized you could hold someone
and pointy good I know Metal Gear you
can do that can you do that so explain
as a be like oh you could point a gun
barrel than someone because I people
that I love stealth games
I love the whole sneaking aspect like
there are some friends of mine who just
always want to go in and like just Jack
them up right away waste all their
bullets and I'm like no I'm conserving
so I think for like I'll take forever
because I just I wanted to take as many
people out by my choking I love the
gameplay and like the part in the at the
hospital to where the shy no Rat King
oh my god that scared the crap out of me
and some people are used to the Resident
Evil games probably won't get as phased
but for me it was like just keep just
keep pretty heavy for Last of Us to be
like alright the worst thing you're
gonna come across is like a bloated guy
you're going through Ground Zero where
the first infected in Seattle are before
you've activated all the doors you can
use like hearing to see through them be
like okay there's a couple clickers
there and there and then you see this
new Mass I thought you know it's the
last of us at the sequel you can do some
things but what they're not gonna go
there and then you're an ambulance and
this Resident Evil like yeah it goes
crappy in full-on Resident Evil at that
point yeah the first game it's boss
fights were not very great like it's a
it's either you're charging through like
attacking like rounds of people which is
fun combat or there's though the one
boss fight in Last of Us the first one
where it's against David for people who
know where you just have to sneak around
corners and not step on plates so here's
okay where is this one you're fighting
against Ellie when she has all of her
like yeah there's a lot of like boss
fights here's more like oh there's a
stage a level like when when Abby is
trapped or in an Yara and Lev are trying
to get her yeah and then yeah like that
I kept dying animal yeah I got bad at
dodging dodging wasn't in the first game
so that okay I would have to consciously
remember to die you just have to hit the
button a note I always kept doing it in
a direction I would always go into them
so no just hit the button and you're not
immediately for as much as it's a game
that's a dour and
there's a real fun like game aspect I
can't emphasize that enough
yes I'm so glad you brought that up
because because some people really were
under the impression that all this game
wants to do is break your heart because
while it is bleak while it is morbid
like it ended in a way where I wasn't
like I'm over sure like it ended by the
time you get to its final closing moment
I was like like really melancholy you
know there's no denying that you still
get that video game rush throughout the
whole time while it can be repetitive
cuz you're pretty much doing like the
same crap throughout climb listen sneak
grab supplies kill mm-hmm I think the
puzzles probably could have been a
little harder to solve yeah the whole
all the safes I like all kind of
gimmicky stuff of like it's the date of
a child's birthday and you go to the
calendar and it's like any time counter
to say if I'm like well the answer must
be like right right over there right
yeah I did hear that they program so
that you can crack the safe you can
listen and it will like so which is was
like programmers month I have a launch
ps4 I don't have like a 4k TV game is
perdy this game oh it's beautiful is
very beautiful I thought all the other
supporting characters they were cool
there was no one I really loved Mel gets
too much hate I see a lot of hate for
Mel online I liked her he's the program
Mel gets hate yeah a lot of people don't
like mouth it's like [ __ ] over the
most yeah she gets Brendan and her
boyfriend Haley it's not her and I also
think like she's got a really
interesting performance like I don't
know the model they use is like just
I've never seen a character like that in
a game of like she looks like someone
I'd worked with and her scene where
where Mel calls out me out her [ __ ]
that did so much for me in terms of
being like oh thank god Abbi no she's a
she's a dick yeah be aware the way she
is and what she does he has serious
repercussions like it would annoy me if
it was just like I don't know what
you're talking about like she clearly
has this guilt of I'm aware that what I
do has had led to some terrible things
and I need to change yeah I know it's
it's so easy like again now we've spent
enough time with Abby to like I'd be a
bit more on her side and I'm even like
Mel give me a little easy cuz really or
she has the conversation with Mel of
like well the Sarah fights attacked us
and Mel's like they were
Happy's like I wasn't our fault and now
she brings these kids to Mel yeah and
it's like an you help them and from
Mel's perspective you can be like what
is your game here like your whole life
has been dedicated to a task and it's so
like what's the next one yeah it's it's
all these like differences like sir
you're number 1 Sarah Sarah fight killer
scar killer yeah you know I like Deena
I'd say out of all the characters I like
Dean of the most cuz all comes down to
do I like diversity I do
Isaac Isaac cool guy cool cool cool I
hate it Owen Oh Allie thank God Joel's
dead Oh suck it its review churned very
differently the comments are now
agreeing with no I liked Manny then he
dies I'm sad whoo I like Manny I mean
everyone I like but I wasn't exactly
like they all died in in the departed
way which I thought was yeah fascinating
about Runa but certain characters die in
a way we're just like okay he's been
shot at and it's you know I guess we
would go right that's a we would go real
life that's how death works and
especially with Joel's death of like you
don't plan for it it's just gonna happen
Jesse getting popped in the face I was
like oh okay yeah game that's a bummer
and it didn't redeem itself in my eyes
until you see it from Abby's perspective
where she has Tommy pinned down she's
not trying to just murder him and then a
guy bursts in and she just actively
shoots it like that's in that moment
because the way you see from Ellie's
perspective when you're playing is her
is oh my god this beast of a woman when
you get to the part where with Abby you
see the way she shoots him it's not like
digest but the game does that enough
what I think is a brilliant part of the
game is the farm scene of the game has
established it will kill characters it
is not afraid to a be leaving Ellie and
like her cutting years later on the farm
we are such in her mindset of in which I
think kind of helps justify her going
off to kill a be of we've been with a P
we know that she's made this emotional
resolution she's moved on Ellie doesn't
Ellie doesn't know exactly the whole
games perspective the whole time I'm
going out to the barn with like JJ and
I'm like we both feel like popped in the
head
thinking like is this game gonna end
there's no way they'd end this yeah
there's no way this ends happy and the
paranoia that set in of life is too good
right now did you read any of Ellie's
journal throughout the yeah
yes and like you go into her room during
that section and she's like you see like
all the pages that she's talking about
her skin hurts whenever she hangs up
Joel and it's how this is still eating
at her and like Jessie can talk Dena can
talk about Jessie yeah what I don't get
and all that and I guess I do get all
the hate even after all of this is
people being like she didn't even get to
kill Andy at the end well the people
don't get it that and yeah see the thing
is that's the victory as much as I'd
love to like shake whoever is saying
that and be like you don't get it yeah I
think at the end of the day I can
understand if the whole game is it's
challenging not unlike the task of the
gala easy part of the gameplay yeah it's
accepting and doing what you can to
really understand what the game is
talking about yeah I don't want to
insult anyone who feels that way no
because I get if you feel that way cuz
like I said to game sets you up in a way
where you might not be able to get on
board with Abby yeah if you can't get on
board with Abby but that's a beautiful
thing about that yeah I think that's a
polarizing game yeah and I love that
because it opens itself up to a wide
variety of different emotional reactions
to the way some people most people don't
like the whole Joel being killed thing
but I feel like some people might like
it there people were gonna hate Abby
some people are gonna love Abby some
people gonna hate that ending some
people gonna love that and you know the
game made me mad plenty of times but I
also felt like I'm supposed to be mad at
the game yeah there's very few games
that I think can tie in the
act of playing the game into kind of the
same dilemma as the story that the game
is playing in that kind of the beautiful
thing about video games and what I think
less of us to really like capitalizes on
is that the fact that it is in your
hands they're telling a story it's gonna
their store and they're doing it but it
is so conscious of the fact that you
have to control these characters there
are other games where like you have to
make the tough decision in the cutscene
or like you just have to like do the
thing and you know it was tough but you
got through it this is a game that's
making you an active participant in a
way that is kind of against your will
sometimes whether you're for Elly or
against a B or for a B and against Ali
like there is always an opportunity that
it's using as a game a gaming experience
not just a storytelling device make you
think about the action characters I
think that just kind of gets people
riled up a bit more of like why did I
have to hit the button I didn't want it
like I mean sad some people also hate
that idea though and I can understand
that some people just want only pure
it's like read a book it's like the
people who want you know just the only
the revenge movie of like something that
happens wrong to the guy or girl and
they get revenge some people just want
something that simple to live that
cathartic experience and this game I
think challenges its audiences to see if
they can get on board with trying to
understand and explore it at a deeper
level and so people don't want that like
the game it's a video game
that's striving for this strange
realistic mo not realistic in terms of
what you're doing necessarily but
realistic in terms of the emotion
emotionally grounded yeah yeah and so
for a game to be like we want to make
this feel like as real as possible not
just an aesthetic but in the emotion
yeah I think is bold and it's awesome
that it's pissing people off and the
fact that it's the quickest selling like
ps4 game above spider-man above like
uncharted 4 it's so easy to look at this
cynically and just think of it as cash
grabs but it's funny that none of the
discussion none of the vitriol has come
from gameplay none of it has come from
the fact of it being a video game but
the choices as storytellers to make
daring decisions if that's the result of
all this like I'm kind of for that
because I think you know whether it's
last Jedi or whether it's like yeah some
other piece of content that comes out
and really makes you evaluate your
relationship
with other IP or content or arts you
question it is not to like spit in your
face and say it's bad it's to make you
value
why do you emotionally get invested in I
think last of us too is just another
example of we're not telling the story
that you think you why we're telling the
story we think you need yeah that's a
good way to put it it's not the story of
the last of us it's the story of all of
us that's my that's my haiku right
number of syllables so put that on my
gravestone I loved it I loved getting
caught up in the gameplay too when you
know when your life is running and it's
running faster like we're in action
resolution you're like I just killed you
yeah it probably could have done a
little bit more with like the actual
infected they didn't really amp that
this game's not about that though anyway
the first one is it it is a little bit
of a Walking Dead kind of thing yeah but
some people are like it just rips off
the llama it's kind of similar sure but
it doesn't just rip off the Walking Dead
it has a really cool progression like
the basic version we're gonna wrap this
up shortly Ali gets set up for the
revenge story she's going on a typical
revenge story and I'm loving it like
what she's first messing up all the wo
laughing you just feel like so badass
you get in the Jeep with freaking Jesse
then slowly you're like oh she's kind of
going down a dark path okay all right
still you know and then and then she
kills Owen and she kills now and you're
like the consequence then you shift into
Abby's perspective I think the game has
a nice progression of getting you from
what you think you're about to play in
two years what we're really gonna deal
with and how both their journeys are
gonna wrap they're gonna coincide with
each other I think it's beautiful I
don't think there needs to be another
Abby story
I think LA desert I'm like I'm really
hoping to hell you can get it happy like
if they do a part three I really want
Ellie to get some kind of happy and
yeah because she's just been like
through pure suffering like most of
these people in the world have but you
know the steel and the last of us happy
that's not a story that because don't
know that in in this kind of world it's
at what cost but that's the point like
what I was talking about of what do you
expect from a video game does it upset
you to not want to do to do a game that
wants to challenge you in that way or
are you like it's a video game I should
be feeling happy and it should just be
fun
or is there a gray area where we can
meet each other at you know what I mean
or can we push this artform forward I
get it this is something a lot of people
care about man am i happy that it exists
in such a life yeah conversational way
that it does I love it I love debating
with people who disagree with me on it
with people who played the Kings kind of
leave it to spoilers I think I got the
gist oh man it was crazy how do people
have such strong opinions who haven't
played the game yeah there are channels
there are YouTube channels who reports
so much negativity on the last of us to
who have never even played the first one
really their videos are skyrocketing and
who do you do you alright good good for
you I'm glad you're profiting whatever
way you can job you figured it out but
just know this if you made it this far
I'm not reading a single comment on this
video
oh wait to talk with people in person
who have played the game because I know
some people who don't really like it and
I know some people who love it and if
you disagree with me at fuels mean yeah
but anyway guys all that being said
thank you pat for being here thanks for
having me Greg and you were someone
who's like the things that stood out to
me the most I was thinking about like
with everyone I know you're they
probably are probably similar things
that stood out with you we're kind of
the same like way out when it comes to
like thematic exploration and character
I was like we probably on the same page
here yeah I don't want to bring awesome
Abhisek Ruby
just an hour of yelling let me talk
that wasn't my intended just wanted me
there are my thoughts after like four to
five hours of sleep beating this game so
I could already do a review we've been
like spacing out just like jonesing at
the chance
morons just ended anger would not have
been fun I don't know how long this
video is gonna turn out to be but we've
currently been feelin for over an hour's
the longest I'd film them quite a while
thank you for being here where can they
find you Pat stay here this long find me
on Hogue underscore filmmaker on Twitter
and Instagram and check out my video
page Patrick Hogue I'm a content creator
oh my god make her oh my god you're
filming her in LA I would die day 1 I
would lay down and seem sad
but check out my short films and my
newest short film so is on Crypt V's
YouTube channel it were over 200,000
views which is pretty cool the reception
has been great and played last of us -
yeah it's a great game alright guys well
first video game review on the channel
it was the longest review I've ever done
this will be the last video game review
this was a horrible next time we need
bullet points capturing of insanity if
you haven't played it but you're like I
don't like you the games really really
what the [ __ ] alright guys subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell thanks so much for being here thank
you again Pat see you guys soon